this morning on the dish banker turned
Baker on Brock Maud born to Pakistani
immigrants in Michigan she excelled in
school graduating from MIT and earning
two more degrees before starting a
career in investment banking one of her
business clients was world-famous chef
Tom Colicchio and when he sampled the
incredible dessert she baked as a hobby
he encouraged her to make it a career he
advised her as she opened mozz Adar her
award-winning pastry shop in New York's
West Village chef amber Ahmad good
morning good morning I do as well would
you bring us chef oh my goodness you
brought you a whole bunch of different
pastries and starting with our
award-winning brioche doughnuts filled
with vanilla pastry cream I don't know
starting there no you should definitely
start there then we have our vanilla
choux which is our version of a puff
pastry that has a vanilla pastry cream
inside we have a devil and ganache cake
with chocolate on chocolate on chocolate
and we have cross all a booster no well
for the holiday which is just really
gorgeous and delicious and we have a
whole bunch of other things we have a
braids with house-made I'm candied
hazelnuts and Nutella and cinnamon and
in the front is the misoo which is the
first thing I learned how to make it is
a very traditional finished bread that's
made with milk cardamom and almonds and
some savory as well and our lady yes
these are some dishes actually I'm
family recipes of ours I'm the one in
the front is lamb and rice which is a
very traditional Punjabi dish and that
takes hours and hours to make and it's
just fills the entire house with a sort
of sense of love which is wonderful and
bastia which is a Moroccan dish that my
parents learned to make very very early
on in my childhood
you mentioned the Finnish bread the
first thing you learn to make 1 CH and
why how did that happen it's a good
question so my family's from Pakistan
yeah and we settled in northern Michigan
as Pakistanis do it's one yes exactly we
were the only sort of non finished
Swedish Norwegian family in the region
everybody was always sort of surprised
the fact that we didn't have blond hair
and we were raised and part by a woman
who was from Finland she became our
nanny but she was like our grandmother
and she became part of our family and
she used to bake and baking was a really
special time for us
because she would take me in wrap me in
blankets and she put me on the counter
and she would tell me stories and her
hands would be moving in the food but
her mouth would be telling me all these
great sort of stories that it's just
incredible and so I from very early age
it just had an inextricable link between
storytelling yeah and family and food
yeah and so misoo was of one of the
first things she taught me how to make
anything thank you finished nanny think
there's a lot of unlikely in your story
how'd you go from someone with so many
incredible degrees to baking we're happy
that you mean thank you
well you know everybody thinks that I
just kind of blacked out one day
business and the reality is is I took
everything that I knew how to do and I
applied it to what I love to do and so I
took the financial skills
I took the science behind you know how
things interact with each other
I took the fundraising that I used to do
and decided to actually do it for myself
and so I think there comes a time when
sometimes in your life you you take what
you love to do and what you know how to
do and you actually turn it into a
profession when Tom Colicchio asked you
to do this yes what did you say it first
well he found out that I made food
through mutual friends and he said to me
I heard you make pastry and I said okay
and he said I want to try your food I
was like that's ridiculous you make
people cry on TV I am NOT a sadist I
mean a little bit but I'm not about to
make you food anything I want to try it
so I said all right I'll start actually
you know making things for you so I
spent about three days making every
piece of pastry knew how to make them
cakes and pies hearts and scones and
biscuits and everything and he would
take a few bites and he just pushed it
aside and for whatever reason I would
suspend my disbelief and show up the
next day with more food and finally on
the third day he looks at me says what
do you want to do with this and I said I
I want to do for myself what I've done
for many years from other people I want
to create the next great heritage brand
ah and he said let's do it too we love
the brand thank you Tom for encouraging
me as a gift
chef if you could share this with any
figure past or present who would it be
my mom good call yeah she died three
weeks before the bakery opened she would
be so proud and we are so thrilled that
you're happy
congratulations on all of your sinks
thank you wish you the best we can't we
do to eat it all from Lauren chef Ahmed
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning calm